so the communities most at risk actually
want to defund the police we already
know the answer
amid last summer's blm riots gallup
found that 81 percent of black americans
wanted police to spend the same amount
of or more time in their neighborhoods
here now with me dr ben carson former
hud secretary founder of the american
cornerstone institute
dr carson um these racial radicals
are signaling to someone out there
thinking they're connecting with someone
on this message of defund the police but
these cities are in a free fall
well obviously the people who need the
police the most
are the people who are in dangerous
situations like many of these inner
cities
and you know when you stop and you think
about what the police go
through we need to just learn how to be
a little more compassionate and think of
put ourselves in other people's shoes
they get up every morning put that
uniform on they don't know if they're
coming back home every time that
telephone rings their spouse's
heart jumps up into their throat and
now you know you stop a car you don't
know what you're going to encounter
and the sad thing is you know there are
few bad police and a few incidents but
there are millions of encounters with
police
every every week
and you see only a very small number of
these
aberrant cases but we take those and we
magnify them
and try to make it seem like that's
what's going on with everybody if every
profession was treated that way
nobody would look good you know doctors
dentists lawyers tv correspondents
everybody would look bad
if we always judge them on the basis of
the bad apple makes no sense whatsoever
and meanwhile as we were talking about
minneapolis just over the last you know
12
13 hours was reported that you know a
six-year-old seven-year-old little girl
uh was shot and killed uh in the city
um again very very small police presence
it's just and what would you expect
what would you expect if the police are
not
able to do their job because there's so
few of them because so many of them are
retiring
and you know i wonder and i i hope it's
just an aberrant thought
but i wonder if they're trying to get
rid of the police make them all go away
so that they can call on the military
and we can have the same kind of
situation that was in
in washington d.c after january the 6th
i hope that we don't get to that point
but this is the kind of thing that would
set that up
and we need to understand that there are
consequences for these kinds of actions
and we want to continue to have freedom
and the only way you can have freedom
is that you have order law and order
in the right proportions and that
there's no question that there are
things that can be done with the police
and with policing you know there are all
kinds of new technologies that are
available that are non-lethal
we need to be talking about the various
options that exist and how they can be
utilized but more importantly
community policing i talked to a police
officer he said he walks through the
community every day everybody knows them
he never has to buy lunch
everybody loves them and if there's a
problem they tell them
you know those are the kinds of things
that we can do
dr carson thank you so much for being
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else